inquiétude dans la transat les
radioamateurs aller coûte pour retrouver
alain colas fin du congrès de la cgt
georges séguy réélu lance un nouvel
appel à l'unité syndicale
le patronat et la formation
professionnelle elle doit être une
passerelle entre les entreprises et les
demandeurs d'emploi
messieurs bonsoir jusqu alors nous
avions essayé de ne pas trop montrer
notre inquiétude à propos du sort
d'alain colas qui n'est toujours pas
arrivé à pointe-à-pitre mais cette fois
disons le on a vraiment peur pour lui le
bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale est revenue bredouille de sa
mission
la nuit dernière joël charpentier le
trégastellois qui est arrivé 5e hier et
qui avait une journée de retard sur
colas lors du dernier pointage il ya
deux semaines à confronter son journal
de bord avec celui de michel malinovski
lui aussi avait un peu de retard sur
colas il avait choisi de la même beauté
bien une certitude il est arrivé quelque
chose et peut-être quelque chose de
grave
tous les radioamateurs sont d'ailleurs
mobilisés depuis quelques heures pour
essayer de retrouver le navigateur
en tout cas pour essayer de percevoir la
moindre tentative de liaison radio
est ce que vous pourriez sur certaines
fréquences capter les radios des bateaux
sur la route du rhum celle d'alain colas
par exemple qui met aujourd'hui à titre
exceptionnel où nous avons droit
d'écouter les fréquences hautes que
celles qui sont radio amateur et compte
tenu des circonstances le plus
exceptionnel
disons un peu effectivement aujourd'hui
et vous avez reçu quel instruction
uniquement des comptes et de noter le
nom du bateau les coordonnées
géographiques de ce bateau et de
retransmettre toutes ces informations en
station côtière officielle qui se sont
chargés de faire mes recherches après le
repérage et maintenant la recherche
le bréguet atlantique de la marine
nationale qui avait été jusqu'ici pour
des missions de repérage des
concurrentes est il de recevoir les
consignes de fouiller l'atlantique à la
recherche des solitaires dont on est
sans nouvelles
cette première mission de sécurité de
sauvetage est d'effectuer hier au large
d'îlots de cocoa vous êtes et échoué
gouvernail cassé le trimaran vsd pendant
deux heures
le bréguet atlantique a survolé l'épave
endommagée du voilier jusqu'à fait qu'un
petit canot à moteur a prié par le
manège de cet avion se porte au secours
de jeunes riguidel qui est du pays sain
et sauf
cette mission accomplie le break et a
survolé pendant toute la journée
la zone dans laquelle sont supposés la
ligue et les voiliers de cette phrase
aujourd'hui un autre breguet atlantic
partie des acteurs sur vos lui aussi les
routes de la courte mais malgré la brume
ans les plus perfectionnés dans un cerf
la marine nationale
il faut bien reconnaître que sa tâche
n'est pas facile cherchez un voilier
dont on est mené par la position depuis
longtemps c'est presque aussi difficile
que de chercher une aiguille dans une
botte de foin et c'est le cas
précisément de velours et 20 le voilier
d'alain colas dont on a perdu la trace
depuis quinze jours
sa famille inquiète est intervenu pour
que des recherches approfondies cette
entreprise
or ces deux repreneurs poteau soir
qu'elles n'ont pas abouti ce qui
commence à devenir inquiétant mais les
solitaires qui sont déjà arrivés après
dati refuse de croire à la catastrophe
et préfère penser que alain colas
l'équipe d'alinghi dans vos techniques
rallier pointe-à-pitre avec des moyens
de fortune et que dans ces conditions le
retard est tout à fait explicables
oui alain colas n'êtes pas le seul
navigateur dont on est sans nouvelles
c'est aussi le cas du guadeloupéen
jacques pallas et d'un certain nombre de
concurrents tout à l'heure
jacques timsit a pris la sixième place
devant philippe poupon abords du vieux
paix nouic 3 d'eric tabarly
florence arthaud elle la première femme
donc concurrente devrait arriver dans
les heures qui viennent
deuxième incertitude ce soir dans
l'actualité la santé du président
boumédiène toujours le silence à alger
depuis le bulletin de santé plutôt
optimiste dimanche plus rien d'officiel
en tout cas simplement cette information
que je vous donnais hier la présence non
pas d'un mais de deux caillots de sang
visiblement le président algérien est
inopérable il est d'un état de coma
profond peut-être même de coma dépassé
alors se pose maintenant bien sûr le
problème de l'acharnement thérapeutique
et on a bien sûr envie de vous pouvez
être à l'ombre de questions martine
arogno alors tout d'abord le première
question 60 médecins autour d'un la
seule valable est ce bien utile utile
sûrement pas de presque 19 1 français
que j'ai interrogé les 60 médecins
ajouté de 13 nationalités différentes
qui ne parlent pas la même langue
alors pour la thérapeutique sûrement pas
pour la politique je ne sais pas il faut
parfois ménager les deux quand il s'agit
d'un chef d'état en réalité on me dit
qu'un très bon réanimateurs polyvalent
qui surveille toutes les défaillances
rénales respiratoires cérébrale et qu'il
y ait une autre équipe à rechercher la
cause de tous ces maux est largement
suffisante est même allé il paraîtrait
qu'il ya de très bons réanimateur alors
disons le en a pas de bulletin de santé
quotidien ne s'est donc pas trop ce
cadre le président nommé diane à la fois
très peu dans effectivement nous vivons
et des rumeurs des hypothèses parfois
contradictoires je n'ai vu monsieur vous
m'aidiez à nice et 69,1 donc nous
parlons avec des hypothèques
le problème numéro un c'est bien sûr le
cerveau puisque c'est de là les premiers
touchés 13 milliards de cellules
nerveuses de neurones sont dans notre
tête nous en perdons nous mêmes chaque
jour mais lorsqu une hémorragie
cérébrale et un caillot se forme nous en
perdons en masse et c'est irréversible
ce que les cellules ne seront pas une se
multiplient pas néanmoins dire qu'il
s'agit de coma dépassé ou même de coma
chronique ça les patients nous manquons
d'informations
il pourrait très bien sortir de son coma
personne ne veut se prononcer en
l'absence d'informations un coma
chronique au bout de plusieurs mois
et si comme on le dit il est en coma
dépassé c'est à dire que son électro
encéphalogrammes est totalement plat ça
ne devrait pas dépasser 2 par jour
alors se pose maintenant le problème de
l'acharnement thérapeutique oui ces
phénomènes qu'on déconnecte franco
initiés
général franco et qui pose bien des
problèmes mais les médecins là aussi le
diront que en réalité il n'abandonne
après plusieurs jours que 5 à 10% des
cas les plus désespérés et que quand il
s'agit d'un chef d'état on pourrait
tellement être accusé de ne pas avoir
fait l'impossible qu'il faut aussi les
comprendre de ce côté là sur le plan
thérapeutique alors deuxième question
toujours à propos des chefs d'état celui
du sel du secret médical dans le secret
médical c'est un éternel problème là je
me référais au président profil est
aussi on a voulu savoir de quoi il était
atteint savoir si c'était compatible
avec le pouvoir
c'est un état d'un problème on ne peut
pas les je vais seulement sur le pot les
chefs d'état s'est aussi fait un
commandant de bord et peut-être aussi
pour le présentateur du journal
disons simplement qu'on souhaiterait de
temps en temps quand cette bêta et doit
et droit comme premiers employés de
l'état elle marie travaille pour nous
nicolas ceausescu persiste et signe le
chef de l'état roumain a réaffirmé avec
vigueur ce qui l'opposait et ceux qui
l'unissait aux autres pays socialistes à
l'occasion du 60e anniversaire de la
création de l'état national romain
anouar el sadate n'ira pas à oslo le 10
décembre pour la remise de son prix
et pourtant il l'avait laissé entendre
souvenez-vous il ya quelques semaines
lorsqu'il avait téléphoné eau colorée à
menahem begin anouar el sadate se fera
représenter par son assistant et jimmy
carter s'est dit mécontent déçu et
quelque peu découragé des retards pris
par les négociations israélo égyptienne
une dernière minute à propos de
l'étranger des coups de feu en iran de
coups de feu près de l'ambassade de
grande bretagne dans le centre de la
ville de téhéran avec une manifestation
à l'appeler en france maintenant
d'abord cet emprunt de cinq milliards
qui sera lancé le 12 décembre ce sera le
quatrième emprunts depuis le début de
l'année caractéristiques identiques aux
précédents sauf pour le taux qui est
ramené de 9 points 45% à 8,81 % cet
appel à l'épargné destinée à compenser
le déficit général déficit de vous le
savez qui n'a cessé de s'accroître
depuis plusieurs années des chiffres
encore 2 milliards 25 celle enveloppe
gouvernement a décidé de consacrer à la
réalisation d'un plan quinquennal pour
informatiser le pays
l'informatique nous vous l'avons souvent
répété antenne 2 depuis septembre ce
sera la grande affaire des années à
venir
on imagine mal l'importance que va
prendre la télématique dans ses
applications les plus concrets
simon aura et alain minc avait contribué
à alerter l'opinion en présentant un
rapport rédigé à la demande du
gouvernement
aujourd'hui donc le gouvernement veut
lui donner des applications immédiates
il faut faire de la france une société
informatisée le japon les etats-unis ont
ouvert une voie dans laquelle le
gouvernement veut maintenant nous faire
avancer
voilà pour l'objectif reste le programme
d'action alors il ya deux axes
essentiels d'abord la formation et
l'enseignement ensuite la diffusion des
applications de l'informatique
pour le premier point c'est dans la rue
qu'il faut faire descendre l'ordinateur
c'est à dire d'abord à l'école aussi
bien dans le secondaire que dans
l'enseignement supérieur et ceci par
l'installation de petits ordinateurs
quant à la diffusion des applications de
l'informatique
elle devra se faire dans plusieurs
grands domaines notamment dans
l'industrie et aussi dans les petites et
moyennes entreprises
une agence dépendant du ministère de
l'industrie sera chargé de coordonner
les actions de l'état et de répartir les
crédits nécessaires les sectes
religieuses en accusation à l'assemblée
nationale alain vivien député socialiste
a dénoncé la prolifération de ces sectes
il dit avoir été menacés par certains de
leurs membres de même d'ailleurs qu'un
autre parlementaire emmanuel hamel
christian bonnet le ministre de
l'intérieur est favorable à une mission
d'information sur ces sectes fin du
congrès de la cgt fapt en chansons il
paraît que georges séguy a entonné
montagne pyrénées avec sa femme et comme
henri krasucki lui a poussé la
chansonnette sur à la bastille alors
tous à nous passer ni dans les pyrénées
ni à paris mais à grenoble ou plus
sérieusement georges séguy a été réélu
secrétaire venir
le nombre de secrétaires confédéraux
socialiste est porté de 1 à des villans
ce congrès jacques mouline
après six longues journées de débats et
de votes la cgt après fectivement un
nouveau visage dans un climat détendu
elle après l'apprentissage de la
discussion et de la critique
et puis elle a un peu plus ouvertes ces
instances dirigeantes au courant de
pensée autre que communiste
puisque maintenant sept socialistes
contre 4 auparavant si l agression
exécutive c'est donc une victoire pour
georges séguy qui avait lancé ce pari de
l'ouverture
une ouverture qui toutefois est loin
d'être une révolution les différents
rapports soumis au vote ont été votée à
la quasi unanimité et le point chaud de
la discussion comme le cumul des mandats
syndicalistes et politiques ou la
critique de l'engagement de la cgt lors
de la dernière campagne électorale nous
pas donné lieu à une véritable remise en
cause la cgt est elle devenue plus
indépendant le véritable test
interviendra dans les prochains mois
lors des sélections européennes et l'on
verra alors si l'engagement pris 6 de
rester non de cette campagne sera plus
et puis il reste surtout le sentiment
que ayant remis sa montre à l'heure
la cgt semble désireuse de retrouver le
chemin de la négociation et de la
politique cours actuel après le
recentrage de la cfdt
c'est bien un recadrage syndical cgt
auquel ont assisté durant ce congrès est
bien la cfdt a dit qu'elle examinerait
avec sérieux et attention les débats de
ce congrès de la cgt edmond maire a par
ailleurs relancé la négociation sur le
temps de travail en écrivant au patronat
et aux autres syndicats et en faisant de
nouvelles propositions les propositions
plus souple qui vont peut-être permettre
une issue positive à la prochaine
rencontre sur ce problème
mardi prochain en attendant examiner ces
propositions le cnpf s'est penchée
pendant deux jours à deauville sur la
formation permanente devant 800 chefs
d'entreprise
en schématisant je dirais que c'est une
formule que le patronat préfère à
l'indemnisation à fonds perdus des
chômeurs et françois ceyrac a proposé
deux solutions nouvelles à la fois pour
les jeunes et pour y ait plus de 50
la nouveauté pour les jeunes c'est la
formation alternée le patron prend la
relève de l'enseignant pendant deux ans
le jeune travailleur fait une sorte de
va et vient entre l'entreprise qui
l'emploie et l'école le cnpf propose de
partager les frais avec l'état
autres propositions nouvelles pour une
meilleure réinsertion des chômeurs de
plus de 50 ans on proposerait à ses
chômeurs un nouvel emploi même de courte
durée dans une entreprise couplé avec un
enseignement une formation le salaire
serait payée par le patron et les
charges sociales ça a payé par l'état
le cnpf parient sur le fait que cet
emploi d'une durée limitée au départ
deviendrait ensuite très rapidement
permanent ce sont des mesures qui nous
paraissent importantes et efficace parce
que même dans une situation difficile de
l'emploi comme celle que vous évoquez
elles peuvent être utiles et
immédiatement utiles immédiatement utile
pour les jeunes est immédiatement tous
styles pour les chômeurs de plus de 50
et je crois que je vous regarde les
choses comme elles sont si on peut être
aujourd'hui utile il faut l'être même si
ça ne résout pas complètement le
problème du chômage des sanctions seront
prises contre les boulangers qui
s'entendent pour pratiquer des prix
identiques par exemple en vendant tous
la baguette un franc 40 comme dans les
alpes-maritimes
c'est ce qu'a annoncé rené monory le miz
l'économie en présentant le rapport
annuel
de la commission de la concurrence
manufrance réunion du comité
d'entreprise et des syndicats
aujourd'hui ils demandent une table
ronde pour examiner les formules qui
permettrait de sauver l'entreprise sans
licencier un seul salarié de manufrance
avec pierre-marie thiaville maintenant
les autres conflits du moment
l usine de rive de gier le pdg du groupe
creusot loire a confirmé les craintes
émis ces derniers jours par les
syndicats concernant l'imminence d'un
licenciement massif
on parle d'un chiffre entre 500 et 800
personnes et d'une date à partir du 15
décembre
la réplique des syndicats a été
immédiate et divers débrayages ont eu
lieu aujourd'hui dans les usines du
groupe
situation très tendue également dans le
haut rhin aux mines de potasse d'alsace
où le conflit s'éternise depuis plus de
sept semaines par grève tournante d'un
puits à l'autre et concernées 6300
mineurs la direction considère les
négociations comme close et fo et la cgc
ne paraissent pas disposée à poursuivre
le mouvement mais cet affaiblissement
apparent de l'intersyndicale débouche en
fait sur un durcissement
la cgt et la cfdt ayant répliqué
aujourd'hui par la mise en place de
piquets de grève le mouvement va entrer
dans son troisième mois les marcheurs
venus du larzac dans l'espoir d' exposer
leurs problèmes au président de la
république lui même seront demain devant
paris vingt d'entre eux ont fait
l'ensemble de la route 700km soutenu
matériellement chemin par toutes les
fdsea des départements traversés ce soir
étape à ivry demain à 14 heures arrivée
à la porte d'orléans où l'interdiction
officielle est prêt semblablement des
forces de police les empêcheront de
pénétrer dans paris
j'ajoute que de l'autre côté du rhin le
ton s'est nettement durci dans
l'industrie de la sidérurgie pour la
cinquième journée consécutive le
patronat ouest allemand a fait jouer le
lock out et l'a étendu à 3 à 8 même très
grosses entreprises en grève
distribution des prix à l'elysée
aujourd'hui le chef de l'état soulignant
l'importance des métiers d'art dans la
société moderne récompensé les deux
lauréats pour 78 du grand prix du
priorat public
une restauratrice de tissus anciens est
un fondeur d'art
tu veux pas faire des faits essentiels
et ceux qui resteraient paul d'espis
ration notre époque qu'en face la
production de masse production que nous
savons de mieux en mieux organisés mais
qui porte en elle le danger de
l'uniformisation des goûts et les
habitudes
il importe que soit préservé un secteur
où s'épanouissent la création
individuelle et l'exigence la plus
complexe de la perfection l'émission
c'est l'avis de noël mamère rendra
d'ailleurs hommage aux métiers d'art
dans une série de reportages réalisés
par alain valentini diffusé dans dix
jours et pendant deux semaines premier
portrait de la série monsieur tino le
propre fils du lauréat fondeur d'art
comme son père avec qui il travaille
c'est la fin de l'opération coulage nous
avons certes îles crozet avec le métal
en fusion environ 1,12 cent vingt douze
150 degrés et nous avons rempli les les
moules de métal
non non non je n'ai pas bien pas fini un
peu il reste plus qu'à attendre quelques
minutes que métal sofiges et nous allons
procéder à l'opération de démoulage
on ouvre les moules qui vient d'être
coulé il ya dix minutes un quart d'heure
et on sort les clès brut de fond que la
médaille sortie du moule
il s'agit maintenant de trouver son
alimentation à la scie on découpe autour
de la vie ça y est
il restera ensuite à la patine et à dire
lui donner une couleur ap employés
sa sculpture la médaille n'est pas notre
seule activité
nous faisons aussi les réalisations des
sculptures dont la mante religieuse de
germaine richier une pièce qui demande
quand même beaucoup de travail beaucoup
de soin des pièces de monsieur gilles
violi des riches y ait des v rik et tout
lu tout à un ensemble de sculptures que
vous voyez exposé ici et il faudrait
pouvoir éduquer des jeunes pour remonter
ce métier qui est en train de
disparaître réunion spéciale de la
commission de révision pour se prononcer
sur le cas youssef qui se moon condamne
et vous savez à 20 ans de réclusion pour
un crime qu'il affirme ne pas l'avoir
commis cette commission n'a qu'un
pouvoir consultatif qu'il appartiendra
au garde des sceaux de décider non la
révision du procès il se pourrait que la
décision d'alain peyrefitte soient
connues au début de la semaine prochaine
embouteillage au pied de la tour eiffel
cet après midi une centaine de voitures
spécialement équipé pour participer à la
lutte contre la lèpre et est distribué
aux ambassadeurs de neuf pays africains
un très beau geste de la fondation raoul
follereau celui qu'on a fait le père des
lépreux et à qui jean tous là vient de
consacrer un livre un sondage jeune
afrique louis harris comment les
français d'aujourd'hui juge la
décolonisation et bien pour un français
sur deux est une très large majorité de
jeunes
la colonisation s'est plutôt mal passée
39% des personnes interrogées estiment
que la situation est moins bonne dans
les pays africains depuis leur
indépendance et dans ce même numéro de
jeune afrique une interview de valéry
giscard d'estaing avec cette petite
phrase
l'afrique devra être présente au rendez
vous du troisième millénaire récompense
des bons élèves décidément nous y
restons avec cet après midi la remise
des bourses de la fondation de la
vocation la 19e du nom la promotion 60
18 et patronné cette année par madame
simone veil
la santé depuis près de 20 ans 500
jeunes gens pu réaliser leur rêve
grâce à la fondation de la vocation 26
dossiers ont été retenus par le jury de
cette 19e promotion de la fondation la
promotion bernard halpern
les lauréats 18 hommes huit femmes ont
reçu chacun un chèque coup de pouce de
douze mille francs qui leur permettra
peut-être de réaliser une vocation
souvent contrarié au départ 26 lauréats
dont le plus surprenant est françoise
turban professeur de lettres devenu
maçon mais en tout ces 3000 dossiers qui
ont été déposés la fondation ce qui
laisse à penser qu'au moins ce domaine
il n'ya pas chez les jeunes de crise de
la vocation move ocassion signifie qu'on
ait vraiment quelque chose à dire qu'on
avait feinté ailleurs une volonté de
faire quelque chose et d'arriver vers
soi même c'est un privilège avant une
location et enfourner avec c'est parce
je ne peux pas dire que tous les ans
tout le monde a une vocation c'est même
vous savez assez d'exceptionnel jusque
là est très bien la jeunesse actuelle
parce que je la vois tous les ans et
dans des métiers comme le nôtre étant
donné mon goût drôle de prénom je suis
sollicité d'une façon extraordinaire par
les jeunes
je vois même des vins télé des jeunes
sortants des grandes écoles comme
normale supérieure venir maintenant
revenir un travail différent on a
tellement poussé le diplôme quel qu'il
soit on dirait qu'on a passeport que
maintenant je considère que le procès
dans certains cas cela passe par sa
destination et vous en fait des
malheureux alors que ces gens et ces
jeunes à la voulu aller jusqu'au bout
d'un métier qu'ils ne connaissent pas en
plus alors c'est une méconnaissance
totale de l'entreprise que le métier
manuel est un monsieur merveilleux quand
on peut le pratiquer que je suis le
premier à pousser parmi les candidats
tous les candidats qui sont artisans
pour moi les artisans c'est une c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel en france
parce que nous avons certainement la
main-d'oeuvre la plus intelligente du
monde
oui vous retrouverez l'une de ces
lauréates demain samedi on vous l'a dit
elle est devenu ouvrier maçon c'est
plutôt rare titre du magazine de paul
lefèvre les femmes qui ont réussi en 78
vendredi soirée littéraire avec
apostrophe vous le savez mais tout de
suite les toiles rose de dominique
fernandez à 49 ans ce professeur de
littérature italienne est déjà l'auteur
d'une quinzaine d'ouvragés
jusqu'à présent ils travaillaient sans
bruit mais son dernier livre risque fort
de le jeter en pleine lumière son titre
l'homosexualité
en parle rarement ce qui aboutit pour
les intéressés à une solitude qui
confirme parfois à une mise au ban de la
société
l'étoile rose c'est le triangle rose que
les nazis épinglé sur les vêtements des
homosexuels dans les camps
d'extermination
dans son roman dominique fernandez
décrit le ghetto dans lequel sont
enfermés les homosexuels profondément
artistes mélomanes
il trouve dans les voix androgyne des
collèges anglais le refus d'un monde qui
divise et qui cloisonnent
proust jeûner ou montherlant nous livrer
des expériences tragiques ou en te
dominique fernandez lui fait un
plaidoyer pour la liberté
c'est la première fois qu'un professeur
d'université se déclarent ouvertement
homosexuel l'action du livre se situe
entre 1943 et 1978
david le héros narrateur raconte la vie
des homosexuels en province les
rencontres anonymes la solitude la honte
la méchanceté aussi dans le milieu
parisien et intellectuels bien une
certaine liberté
mais dès qu'on sortait du milieu
intellectuel si vous allez chez ouvriers
de renault 6 énormément d affaires de la
politique vous hanter de paris et à
mesure vous allez dans les villes
grandes ou petites
vous trouvez une
l'hostilité et le refus total et cette
hostilité se manifeste comment ça ça
peut aller de la bo du ricanement à la
brimade
s'il travaille dans un bureau si vous
employez de postes par exemple ou
licenciements ou perdre votre emploi
si vous êtes dans l'enseignement on vire
pas raison c'est exact vont trouver un
prétexte
on peut se faire même chassé de son
logement et des kayaks sont arrivés le
racisme anti homosexuels se rattache
ouvre insiste général des français
l'institut prend 16 extrêmement raciste
conformiste
vous voyez tous les jours ce soit à
l'égard des homosexuels ou les juifs ou
les arabes ou les travailleurs immigrés
ou de tout ce qui ne ressemble pas à la
masse tout ce qui est différent et c'est
pour ça moi je me bats non pas seulement
pour l'homosexualité mais pour le droit
des minorités à être elles mêmes pour
chacun la commission de panure voisins
et l'amant jeu s'être lui-même librement
l'écriture de dominique fernandez n'est
jamais à des tentes
il enregistre au magnétophone tous ces
textes et les corrige après les avoir
écoutés
je connais qui ne seraient pas fâchés
nous contraindre à sortir marqué le
triangle rose ou view de la poitrine et
même qu il force les juifs s'ils osaient
à se recoudre l'étoile jaune sur le
coeur tout le monde ne peut pas avoir
les [ __ ] la couleur de sa peau pour le
désigner au mépris
il titre du roman de dominique fernandez
donc les toiles ross la page de la météo
maintenant temps très froid sur
l'ensemble du pays aujourd'hui vous
l'avez vu quelques éclaircies sur le
midi demain cela va continuer gelé
jusqu'à -10 dans le centre et le nord
sur l'ouest
un temps plus doux avec quand même
quelques pluies dernier rendez-vous avec
l'actualité ce soir le journal de gérard
holtz vers 22h40
au nom de toute l'équipe de la rédaction
d'antenne 2 qui m'a aidé à composer
journal je vous remercie de votre
fidélité
je vous souhaite une excellente fin de
semaine et j'aurai plaisir à retrouver
l'être